social event Oh Jenna did you see that
Lydia's fed up of being single she's 33
and looking for a man in Taipei we're
here to ask a fortune-teller why finding
a man hasn't worked out yet
he says 90% of his business comes from
single women like Lydia looking for mr.
right what did you ask him I asked him
when where I meet my mr. right and when
where he show up and he tell me that in
this year I was I was I think he said
that I would mean a lot of people but he
think I need you like if the people I
met more chance not just judge by the
first impression because because he they
think I'm too emotional that I've when I
first met and I would just say okay I
have feeling or I don't have feelings
that I was judged directly decide fast
that's what's needed at speed dating
events like this one Lydia meets a new
candidate every six minutes for me it's
quite strange to like talk to a stranger
like in very short time because I'm not
used to kind of this guy kind of
activity visit its trendy you just say
hello and try to chat early and
gentlemen it's okay though they'll be
nervous
there are so many single people in
Taiwan that even the government is
organizing single parties
it would appear exams without a father
to me and I'm really nervous
okay
Lydia's single but she's not alone her
sister Sharon is 35 two years older and
still looking for a man both sisters had
relationships but not with mr. right the
parents are worried and they expressed
that in the modest Taiwanese way there
is a fortune-teller says if you want to
bring a good marriage to your unmarried
daughter in a family so you have to
plant a peach tree in front of your
daughter's room so my father said well
it really works so you go to the flower
market and buy me there's a big picture
plants and put it in front of my window
and hope it works but after one years I
didn't take care of a really good so the
peach trees almost died Lydia and Sharon
have two brothers both around 30 years
old they are also similar and like
nearly every unmarried adult in Taiwan
all four still live at home age the
clock is ticking so I would people
advice to my sister is so if you find a
really good man after may be happier one
year get settled on don't waste any more
time the biological clock that's the key
to what we're talking about it seems to
make less noise here than anywhere else
in the world Taiwan has one of the
lowest birth rates on earth the
government supports families with kids
but many don't even get there a third of
all women are single about 60% of single
women in Taiwan say they simply haven't
found the right guy while a smaller
group 13% cite financial reasons for
staying single
scientists say that Taiwanese women are
too well-educated too successful they
don't need a man anymore
I see the results in the parks during
morning Tai Chi sessions Taiwan's
society is getting older and older
and nothing will change as long as love
is getting less and less important for
young women here I'm single so why why
are you single
for work yeah so I'm not to go into
relationships because singer is free you
can drink at night
no goner hope angry they always disturb
my timetable and schedule there are
plenty of opportunities to meet people
in Taipei 2.7 million people live here
there are more single men and women here
in the capital than in any other
Taiwanese city that's just one couple in
Lydia's circle of friends everyone else
is single
on the first glance it's strange that
they're all single on the second glance
I wouldn't kiss someone who ate this
stinky disgusting tofu but that might
just be me of course her friends talk
about their dates but it seems to be
more stressful than for Lydia
to read our boyfriend we are trying to
find someone now
maybe my boyfriend or returning to the
partner as you say Lydia says it's
essential for a boyfriend to like her
family and friends I'd say he better
like a good party too I'm finding it
hard to imagine that everyone here is in
their mid-30s
I feel taken back to my teenage years
Lydia says she's looking for a man but I
get the feeling that she's not really
suffering so let's bring on the shock
therapy for many single people I know
and for me too
weddings are a nightmare a romance
overload sometimes you feel like a home
maybe when is your turn something and
when you are chatting with friends
girlfriends USA that you were a match
for kind of dress you will won't wear on
your wedding dress yeah sometimes you
feel okay you wish that the moment come
earlier something oh you look nice yeah
strange for you yeah me as well maybe
because
I don't know strange I have to say I'm
realistic they will keep asking that
when I get married you are next time
you're on your next one then sometimes
this kind of comment something and how
does it make you feel when they say that
in the beginning of your all pressure
but in the end of the cycle okay okay
yes instances I would get one very quick
very quick so it kind of you get used to
this kind of a comment already so in
Taiwan there are gods for even the
smallest of everyday problems even one
for love
his name is you Asha and he has a temple
in Taipei
he likes sweets as a sacrifice like many
others Lydia's praying for mr. right to
cross her way
but what if even God can't help I think
it's looking for a partner is very
important but I tried the best person
it's done then you will try to leave by
yourself and try to do the things that
makes you happy
maybe Lydia's right and you have to take
it that easy love is great sure but in
the end maybe the ones will find it the
easiest are the ones who are not
searching for love